last episode we had your buddy here and
we he told me about this thing where he
had invested in the company that's doing
drone window-washing yes I thought that
was crazy fascinating and I went and
researched in a bunch there's another
competitor that's raised money and
drones I don't think are the right words
to describe it because when I think of
drones I think of like a quadcopter
these are things that like they look
like the normal so when you're pulling
up the scaffolding or when you're
pulling up like the what do you call it
it's like an elevator
yeah an elevator up and the guys are
standing on it wiping it looks like that
but there's a robot on there that is
doing it instead of people right so it's
not flying you're saying it's not flying
why do they call it a drone bin because
technically it is robot drone means
honor unmanned vehicle I think ok so
technically the right and so another
company called sky I forget was called
they raised three million to do this and
so this morning what I did and yesterday
morning is I went to I googled Manhattan
skyscraper window cleaners and I found
like the top three four people and I
called them today to talk to them and I
got and I was talking to them and
they're gonna call me back with some
more details but my takeaway from this
industry is incredibly uh segmented so
like fragrance fragmented like small
like twenty to ten to twenty million
dollar businesses and there's probably
five or ten of them in New York right so
it's like the guy Brian from 100 GOT
JUNK right this is how the hauling
business was and you know before he sort
of started aggregating all these small
fragments and local players and you've
always had this thesis which is you
could do the 1-800 GOT JUNK model for
other businesses yeah so I would do it
for irrigation for lawn mowing for
painting which is already happening and
for landscaping right and it sounds like
window washing is in that vein yeah so
maybe you don't even need these freaking
drones to do it but that's definitely a
cool stick so the private equity play is
you go you buy up these businesses they
have a book of business they do
recurring revenue probably with the same
buildings and you say okay I'm gonna buy
this five million dollar a year business
for eight
or ten million tell me ten million bucks
or you do smaller ones you buy a bunch
of $1,000,000 a year businesses and then
you could bring in this technology to
increase the efficiency so they're
getting 50% margin you could get 70% and
there's two playbooks to look at if you
wanted to replicate this
the first is dentists so PE right now is
gobbling up dentists --is dentistry
that's just dentists we have friends who
are doing this yes you have like three
like see ever looked into doing it and
then like two other guys I think we know
they love it and so what they do is they
find a dentist that does two million a
year in revenue and they buy the keys
like sixty ready to retire in a few
years and they buy it for maybe if it's
like a three million dollar revenue
thing they probably buy it for like a
million dollars yeah but basically
they'll buy it at like one I think one
to two X Y Berta which is crazy yeah so
basically they pay back your money in a
urine yeah so they buy it for the
dentist's a--'s salary right times two
and they give him you know you still
keep this little piece and you keep
getting your salary but you don't have
to run this business anymore
in the sort of all the administration
and marketing and they centralize it so
they'll go buy ten of these dentistry's
and then they'll put it'll be like okay
well have one central office that's
doing Facebook Ads driving traffic to
all these will bring all your billing
stuff into one central place cuz why do
you need four people doing billing
because health insurance is you know all
complicated and so they centralized
which makes each one more efficient and
basically the dentist is already playing
golf two days or three days a week and
they're like look here's a you know
accelerated retirement for you and the
goal here is you just you kind of become
a little bit of a just a marketing
company right so we're well we missed
the punchline though a couple of these
roll-ups I think like in Canada seventy
percent of dentists you know numbers
wrong but something like that a huge
percentage of the of all the dentist's
office have been rolled up now in Canada
and a couple of them have been taken
public the roll-ups one for three
billion dollars name um I don't know the
names okay yeah because I'm because
anyway if you want a Google dentistry
roll up Canada it goes public I would do
that and then the other model that you
can look at for this is
all people homes nursing homes like so
many PE I mean this is like so my wife's
dad owns three senior care facilities
yeah and so I was looking into this cuz
I was like wow this thing is a cash cow
and I think it's soul-crushing that's
the problem with it because he was like
hey you guys want to take this over and
we were just like oh the money is there
but like it sucks I don't want this to
be like my life you know like I think in
general people want to avoid nursing
homes at all cost and so getting into it
earlier than you need to was painful but
he's making money - how much does it
make a month you know it depends on the
size so so basically with the bottle is
you go and you you can buy an existing
nursing home but what he looks for is he
says okay this is existing nursing home
it's got 28 beds but it's permitted for
42 and so he'll either just buy it he'll
build out the other beds and so and then
the other thing is he'll buy things that
are motels today so motel the room or
the bed might rent for like I don't know
150 dollars a night and so that becomes
let's call it 4 grand you know it's a
month and what he does is for for senior
care you're charging 7 grand 8 grand
here in California for each bed and you
can put two beds in a room and then you
could do memory care special you know
dementia ward on the bottom and that's
like 12 grand and so just put all the
[__] up cells into it the problem is
is that your up cell is a dementia ward
you know so it's like all right clearly
a lot of money can be made you are
definitely providing but there's a
service to people yeah you're not
scamming people right scamming people
it's but it is a it's a it's a saddening
business to be in yeah and so for these
so we're getting off track but let's go
so so my father-in-law owns a moving
company in New York and it's a medium
middle medium sized business and it's
done the same amount like let's say
let's just say some number between 10
and 30 million in sales every single
year and real profitable I go how do you
make this bigger he goes I'd have to buy
every one out and I don't feel like
doing I got a good life and so I would
you could do that for these window
things and if I was one of these a drone
window companies I would that's what you
would do yeah
[Music]